Michael Cohen heads to the hill to
testify against President Trump
controversy continues over Trump's
national emergency declaration and from
sin Vietnam to meet with the North
Koreans I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
[Music]
well it's a big morning and I understand
that there are people who are watching
the Cohen testimony live but we're
breaking it down for you here because he
already pre released all of his
testimony I don't think there's gonna be
a lot new be on his testimony that he
has already released so we're gonna get
through all of that this morning we are
also going to get into the possibility
of nuclear war between India and
Pakistan which is like the third biggest
story and get to all of that in just one
second first let's talk about how to
make your house safer and more secure
rigs mission is to make neighborhoods
safer you might already know about their
smart video doorbells and cameras that
protect millions of people everywhere
ring helps you stay connected to your
home anywhere in the world so if there's
a package delivery or a surprise visitor
you will get an alert and you'll be able
to see hear and speak to them all from
your phone that's thanks to HD video and
two-way audio features honoring devices
we've had a ring feature on our house
for a long time it's great because it
means that anytime anybody rings the
doorbell we know exactly who is there
whether I'm 3,000 miles away or whether
I'm inside the house as a listener you
have a special offer on a ring starter
kit available right now make your home
safer with a video doorbell and
motion-activated floodlight cam the
starter kit has everything you need to
start building a ring of security around
your home just go to ring.com slash Ben
that is ring.com slash Ben go check it
out right now
ring.com slash Ben once again we have a
ring video doorbell at our house we've
built the ring of security around our
house and it is just fantastic it makes
us feel more safe and more secure go
check them out at ring.com slash Ben
that is ring.com slash Ben for a special
offer on a ring starter kit available
right now all right the big news of the
morning of course Michael Cohen heads to
the hill now this is his only public
testimony he testified before the Senate
Intelligence Committee yesterday that
was behind closed doors and then there
is the the Senate committee that he's
going to speak to tomorrow that is also
behind closed doors today is the only
public testimony that Michael Cohen will
be giving suffice it to say Republicans
are very unhappy with Michael Cohen
Democrats basically have stopped
visiting pornhub for the day because the
Cohan testimony is on live on c-span so
there's plenty to watch if you are a
Democrat we're gonna go through Michael
Cohen's testimony right now so he
released he pre released his written
testimony this is normal in
congressional hearings you released a
written version of the testimony that
has given to members of the committee so
they can prepare their questions I would
not expect that the questions are going
to elicit
much in the way of new information
basically Republicans are gonna try to
impeach the witness and Democrats are
going to try to build up his credibility
that's essentially how the day is going
to go on the hill but here is what
Michael Cohen testified well he began by
asking the committee to ensure that his
family be protected from presidential
threats and that the committee be
sensitive to the questions pertaining to
ongoing investigations the reason he
says this is because over the last
several weeks the President of the
United States has tweeted out stuff
about Michael Cohen's father-in-law and
then last night Matt Gaetz who is a
Republican from Florida tweeted
something out that is quite wild he
tweeted out that mmm that Michael Cohen
should essentially watch his back when
it comes to allegations about him and
other women gets tweeted out hey Michael
Cohen 212 that's at Michael Cohen do
your wife and father-in-law know about
your girlfriends maybe tonight would be
a good time for a chat I wonder if
she'll remain faithful when you're in
prison she's about to learn a lot and
then weirdly enough Matt Gaetz went and
actually got Frank pant Angelis brother
to sit behind Michael Cohen in the
witness hearing hey this is not a good
luck okay it's actually a violation of
law you are not allowed to threaten a
witness it's pretty obvious this is
called threatening a witness here was
here was Matt gets been doing the same
thing on the House floor I guess
tomorrow we will find out if there is
anyone that Michael Cohen hasn't lied to
we already know he lied to Congress we
already know he lied to law enforcement
lied to the IRS lied to three banks and
he's going to prison for his lies and so
I guess it will be relevant for us to
determine like does he lie to his own
family does he lie to his finance ears
do he lie to his finance ears who are
members of his family and it'll be one
heck of an inquiry for us
because this is someone who has tangled
such a web of lies that he is not to be
believed and I think it is entirely
appropriate for any member of this body
to challenge the truthfulness and
veracity and character for the people of
a history of lying and have a future
that undoubtedly contains nothing but
lies I mean not to put too fine a point
on it but it's very weird to go after
Michael Cohen's personal life with
regard to his girlfriends while
defending the President of the United
States who literally has slept with
everything okay that's that's a bit
the reason that we're having a hearing
today is because president Trump the
porn star back in 2006 and then tried to
pay her off with a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars via Michael Connelly
this is a very weird line of attack
Nancy Pelosi then of course got up and
warned Matt Gaetz
and suggested that the ethics committee
could be looking into all of this she
said I encourage all members to be
mindful that comments made on social
media or in the press can adversely
affect the ability of House committees
to obtain the truthful and complete
information necessary to fulfill their
duties okay so that was the lead up to
Michael Cohen's testimony this morning
and it's not a good look okay that's not
something Republicans should be engaged
and not only that it I mean it's
disgusting frankly to be threatening
witnesses with by the way nudge nudge
you may have girlfriends and your wife
doesn't know about that like come on
come on here's the truth it is not very
difficult to impeach Michael Cohen's
witness he's a convicted perjurer he
pled guilty to perjuring himself before
Congress if you want to cast doubt on
his accounts all you have to do is say
right last time you were here you were
lied you were lying to us and you're
going to jail over it so I'm gonna go
with no on everything you say unless
you've got some corroborating evidence
okay in any case Michael Cohen goes
before the committee and he talks about
President Trump now most of what he had
to say is just simple gossip most of it
doesn't go to actual crime it's
essentially juicy stuff that makes
people feel the way they've already felt
about Trump so if you're a big Trump fan
you're gonna dismiss most of this as
bitter grapes from Michael Cohen and
sour grapes from Michael Cohen that he
essentially is just digging up
everything bad he can say about Trump so
that he can rehabilitate himself in the
eyes of the media and in the eyes of the
left so he can get that strange new
respect that James Comey and former FBI
Acting Director Andrew McCabe have
gotten from the left and so if you're a
Republican that's basically where you're
gonna go with this if you're a Democrat
you're gonna say right this is what I
always knew about Trump I always knew he
was a racist and a liar and a cheat now
if you're somebody like me and you tend
to believe that the president has some
fundamental lacks of character because
he does if you're somebody who looks at
this as objectively as possible there
are three baskets into which Cullen's
testimony Falls one is legal problems
like legal impeachable problems for the
president there's not much in the way of
that in this testimony we'll get to that
basket number two is stuff that is
upsetting but not impeachable and Baskin
three is stuff that is just funny as
hell okay and they're really there
they're those three categories in this
testimony all three are here so let's go
through Michael Khan's testimony we're
gonna do it in shorter fashion so you
don't actually have to listen to Michael
Cohen's interminable recitation of his
own testimony because number one I read
faster than he doesn't number two I cut
out all the self congratulatory nonsense
so Michael Cohen led off by saying that
many people doubt and attacks his
credibility he says it is for this
reason I've incorporated into this
opening statement documents that are
irrefutable and demonstrate that the
information you will hear is truthful
and accurate now that is true about some
of the things he says it is not true
about others of the things he says so
his most damning claims about President
Trump the only one that has really
backed by any documentary evidence his
stuff we already knew like president
from signing checks to Michael Cohen's
who essentially reimburse him for paying
off stormy Daniels in the middle of the
election cycle that stuff has some
documentary evidence but we knew that
already the most damning claims the
stuff where he suggests that Trump knew
about WikiLeaks and Julian Assange which
we'll get to in a second or the stuff
where he suggests that Trump knew about
the Trump Tower meeting there's no
documentation of that whatsoever not
only that but the language Trump even
used according to Michael Cohen's own
recitation of the facts is substantially
vague enough that it makes it very
difficult to believe that Trump was
actively involved for example in Russian
collusion in any case Cohen says never
in a million years did I imagine when I
accepted a job in 2007 to work for
President Trump that he would one day
run for president
why don't you campaign on a platform of
hate and intolerance and actually win
now this is Cohen's pitch for guys you
really should love me like please love
me this is his pitch to Elijah Cummings
and the Democratic members of the House
love me I said the president's a racist
and that he's hateful and intolerant
love me well if you thought all this
stuff dude then why were you on his
campaign as one of his leads on TV I
love all the people who leave and then
they're like oh yeah it was hate and
intolerance that that was the real
problem here with Trump like you were
fine with it for years like you were
fine with it for a long long time dude
like all the way through the campaign
and then beyond the campaign he says I
regret the day I said yes to mr. Trump I
regret all the help and support I gave
him along the way
he said he's ashamed of his own failings
as I'm ashamed my weakness and misplaced
loyalty I'm ashamed I chose to take part
in concealed
mr. Trump's elicit acts rather than
listening to my own conscience I am
ashamed says Michael Cohen because I
know what mr. Trump is he is a racist he
is a con man he is a cheat that of
course is gonna be the punchline and
that will be the headline in the New
York Times Trump's personal attorney :
Trump racist conman cheat right that's
gonna be the line and he knows it he
says Michael Cohen says the Trump was a
presidential candidate who knew that
Roger stone was talking with Julian
Assange about a WikiLeaks trap of
Democratic National Committee emails now
the implication here is that it would be
illegal for Trump to know about it now
there are two claims that are being made
one he knew that Roger stone was talking
to massage about the WikiLeaks drop to
the claim made by Democrats that Trump
was actually helping coordinate with
WikiLeaks ie the Russian government the
drop of the emails nothing nothing in
Cohen's account backs claim number two
so there's evidence for claim number one
namely his testimony that stone had told
Trump that WikiLeaks was gonna drop the
emails there is nothing to claim number
two which is that Trump was then telling
WikiLeaks when and where to release the
emails as we'll get to this may be yucky
but it is not in fact illegal and in
fact it really isn't even a typical in
American politics Cohen says I'm
providing the committee today with
several documents these include a copy
of a check mr. Trump wrote from his
personal bank account after he became
president to reimburse me for the hush
money payments I made to cover up his
affair with an adult film star and
prevent damage to his campaign copies of
financial statements for 2011 to 2013
that he gave to such institutions as
Deutsche Bank a copy of an article with
mr. Trump's handwriting on it that
reported on the auction of a portrait of
himself he arranged for the bidder ahead
of time and then reimbursed the better
from the account of his nonprofit
charitable foundation with the picture
now hanging in one of his country clubs
he's under investigation by the New York
AG for the misuse of Trump Foundation
funds which is why the Trump Foundation
has been temporarily shuttered copies of
letters says Cohen I wrote at mr.
Trump's direction that threatened his
high school colleges and the college
board not to release his grades or SAT
scores okay that's just hilarious
okay I'm sorry like that part remember
there are the three baskets illegal bad
hilarious that last one kind of falls
into hilarious like Trump was so
insecure that he had Michael Cohen
sending letters to Wharton saying don't
release my grades guys like done did but
right
into writing into his college to suggest
that he may not release his SAT scores
right it rode into Fordham and said
don't release my SAT score done day I'm
so brilliant I think it would just
embarrass others if they knew what my
SAT scores where it's come on that's
funny stuff okay I'm gonna get to more
of Michael Cohen's testimony why it's
important why it's not important in just
one second first let's talk about your
impending death now I know that when you
watch these Cohen hearings it just makes
you want to die of embarrassment because
the whole thing is embarrassing but you
shouldn't die before you get life
insurance getting life insurance can
feel like assembling the world's worst
jigsaw puzzle it's confusing it takes
forever and when you're finally done it
doesn't even look cool and then you die
but if you have a mortgage kids or
anyone who depends on your income
it's a puzzle you need to solve policy
genius can help you do it policy genius
is the easy way to get life insurance in
just two minutes you can compare quotes
from top insurers and find the best
policy for you when you apply online the
advisers at policy genius will handle
all the red tape they will even
negotiate your rate with the insurance
company no Commission sales agents no
hidden fees just helpful advice and
personalized service and policy genius
doesn't just make life insurance easy
they also make it easy to find the right
home insurance auto insurance or
disability insurance that your one stop
shop for financial protection so if you
find life insurance puzzling head on
over to policy genius calm in two
minutes you can compare quotes find the
right policy and save up to 40% doing it
policy genius is the easy way to compare
and buy life insurance policy genius.com
go check them out right now policy
genius com make sure you get life
insurance it's the responsible way to do
adulting okay so Michael Cohen's
testimony continues he talks about how
these are steps a long way a pathway of
redemption to him no these are the first
steps toward a book proposal that you
will presumably right after he leaves
jail and then he talks about why he lied
to Congress he says that he lied about
to Congress about Trump negotiating the
Moscow Tower deal now here is the most
important line of the entire testimony
and the one that will be most likely to
be ignored quote mr. Trump did not
directly tell me to lie to Congress
that's not how he operates well if he
didn't tell you to lie to Congress and
you don't have evidence of him
instructing you to commit perjury or
obstruction of justice
you got nothing so this is why when we
talk about the basket of legal problems
for Trump Cohen didn't say anything with
regard to
Russia or perjury that actually
implicates Trump and that's a problem
for Democrats they're gonna focus in on
all the bad stuff Trump has said and
done over the course of his career and
let's face it is anyone surprised by any
of these things by the revelation that
Trump's women and then pays them off by
the revelation that Trump says
politically incorrect and/or racist
things in private like is anybody
shocked by any of these things really
hey but and even if those are true right
which we don't know because the only
person testifying is now a convicted
perjurer
but if Trump did not instruct Cowen's
who lied to Congress then he is not
responsible for Cohen's perjury Cohen
says in conversations we had during the
campaign at the same time I was actively
negotiating in Russia for him he would
look me in the eye and tell me there's
no business in Russia and then go out
and lied to the American people by
saying the same thing in his way he was
telling me to lie okay well it is true
that Trump lied over and over and over
about Russia ongoing business and all of
that
not perjury not a crime candidates lied
to the American people all the time
doesn't mean it's good as I have said
1,000 times in this segment alone
president Trump is a man with a deep
lack of character that is obvious he is
not a good man President Trump he may do
some good things that you like he may do
some good things that I like you may be
happy that he's president I'm happy
Hillary Clinton is not president there
are a lot of things to like about
president Trump but it is difficult to
claim that he is an honest good man
because I don't think that that's the
case frankly but is that criminal is it
criminal to not be an honest good man if
it were half the presidents who have
ever been president would have been in
jail because come on we're gonna get two
more of Michael Khan's testimony here in
one second so Michael Cohen continues he
says there are at least a half dozen
times between the Iowa caucus in January
2016 and the end of June when Trump
would ask me how's it going in Russia
referring to the Moscow Tower project
you need to know that mr. Trump's
personal lawyers reviewed and edited my
statement to Congress about the timing
of the Moscow Tower negotiations before
I gave it to be clear mister fromm new
oven directed the Trump Moscow
negotiations throughout the campaign and
lied about it he lied about it because
he never expected to win the election
hey this is another really important
line from Michael Cohen Trump lied about
this stuff because he never expected to
win the election so the going democratic
theory was that Trump made a deal with
Russia for a quid pro quo you say yes to
my Moscow Tower deal and when I win
election I will give you X Y & Z but if
Trump never
to win election what's the quid pro quo
what is the illegal quid pro quo is that
that he said nice things about Vladimir
Putin cuz it's not illegal
it may be dumb but it's not illegal to
say nice things about Vladimir Putin so
if the idea is Russian collusion and
Trump didn't expect to win
what's the illegal pro quo the answer is
there wasn't one so far as we can tell
from any of the evidence that Michael
Cohen is releasing Cohen says Trump also
lied about it because he stood to make
hundreds of millions of dollars on the
Moscow real estate project and so I lied
about it too
because mr. Trump had made clear to me
through his personal statements to me
that we both knew were false and through
his lies to the country that he wanted
me to lie okay that's plausible it is
plausible that Trump wanted him to lie
but if he did not instruct you to lie or
threaten you with consequences for
telling the truth then that is not
obstruction of justice or subordination
of subordination of perjury over the
past two years says Michael Cohen I've
been smeared as a rat by the President
of the United States the truth is much
different let me take a brief moment to
introduce myself and that's when Michael
Cohen lays out his whole life and he
talks about how wonderful a guy he is he
says he's always tried to live a life of
loyalty friendship generosity and
compassion and then he drops what I
think was the most disgusting line of
his testimony he says my father survived
the Holocaust thanks to the compassion
and selfless acts of others he was
helped by many who put themselves in
harm's way to do what they knew was
right
that is why my first instinct has always
been to help those in need
dude do not compare yourself to people
who help save people from the Holocaust
like just come on I don't even go there
you are a gross greasy fixer for a real
estate for a real estate swindler for
years don't like come come the hell on
and this is where Michael Cohen's
testimony begins to break down for me
frankly is that we all know that he's a
convicted liar we know that he's willing
to cheat and cut corners we know all
that stuff but if he wants us to believe
that he is now completely contrite and
he's coming clean because he wants to
unburden himself then leading off with
I'm just like the people who tried that
like my instincts were shaped by my
father's Holocaust survivor ship give me
a break
so Michael Cohen then continues he says
it is painful to admit I was motivated
by ambition at times at times Oh at
times it is even more painful
to admit that many times I ignored my
conscience and acted loyal to a man when
I should not have sitting here today it
seems unbelievable I was so mesmerized
by Donald Trump that I was willing to do
things for him I knew were absolutely
wrong so what exactly did he know about
mr. Trump that was absolutely wrong so
he says that President Trump is an
enigma
he says he's complicated he says he has
both good and bad qualities but his bad
out far far outweighs is good this is
the National Enquirer portion of the
testimony the part where it's bad but
gossipy it's as I said three buckets
illegal bad hilarious okay this is the
stuff that falls into the bad category
for president Trump because it will make
headlines and it's difficult to refute
these claims why because it's a he-said
he-said situation Michael Cohen will
claim that Trump said something Trump
will claim Trump did not say something
people who like President Trump will
believe Trump people who hate Trump will
believe Cohen it's that easy
so Cohen says Donald Trump is a man who
ran for office to make his brand great
not to make our country great he had no
desire or intention to lead this nation
only to market himself and to build his
wealth and power
Trump would often say the campaign was
going to be the greatest information
infomercial in political history now do
I believe this is true yeah probably
he never expected to win the primary he
never expected to win the general the
campaign was a marketing opportunity
true as well as any of that illegal no
is it bad
me I think everybody sort of
acknowledged this at the time now
they're their true believers in
President Trump who believe that
everything the man does he does for
honourable reasons and then there are
people who believe that Trump is a
self-motivated actor and has been
throughout his career but does that
change what he's done as president
doesn't mean that it's bad that he's
president No Cohen then continues he
says I knew early on in my work for mr.
Trump he would direct me colide to
further his business interests I'm
ashamed to say that when it was for real
estate mogul in the private sector I
considered it trivial as president I
consider it significant and dangerous he
says that people lied on his behalf
etc etc and then he says that Trump knew
about the release of the hacked DNC
emails now this is the bucket that
should be illegal but here's the problem
he doesn't actually alleged legal
activity Cohen says as I stated earlier
mr. Trump knew from Roger stone in
advance about the WikiLeaks drop of
emails in July 2016 days before the
Democratic convention I was in mr.
Trump's office when his secretary
announced that Roger stone was on the
phone mr. Trump put mr. spell stone on
the speaker
mr. stone told mr. Trump that he had
just gotten off the phone with Julian
Assange and that mr. Assange told mr.
stone that within a couple of days there
would be a massive dump of emails that
would damage Hillary Clinton's campaign
mr. Trump responded by stating to the
effect of wouldn't that be great
not illegal not illegal if somebody got
on the phone with you and they said your
political opponents about to be hit with
a wave of bad news no matter where it
comes from and you say wouldn't that be
terrific
not illegal and by the way pretty
demonstrative of the fact that Trump was
not openly coordinating with Roger stone
or Julian Assange or WikiLeaks or the
Russian government wouldn't that be
great is an expression of surprise as in
like that would be kind of awesome if
they dropped a bunch of a bomb on
Hillary wouldn't it nothing illegal it
frankly not even anything that bad
they're like what's he supposed to do at
that point
notify the FBI that he thinks that
Julian Assange is going to release
WikiLeaks emails again like it's gonna
be released two days from now I guess he
could notify the FBI but it's not
coordination it's not coordination
knowing about something and not doing
anything about it and not coordinating
about it if somebody says to you two
days from now two days from now
somebody's gonna do something bad to
your business opponent and you're like
oh well that'd be good that'd be kind of
fun
it doesn't make you great no doesn't
make it kind of bad a little does it is
that illegal that's that does not fall
into the illegal basket then Cohen says
that Trump is a racist so Cohen says mr.
Trump is a racist the country has seen
mr. Trump court white supremacists and
bigots you have heard him called poorer
countries bleep holes
okay well as far as him courting white
supremacist and bigots I was very very
critical of President Trump in 2016 from
winking and nodding at the alt-right in
fact one of the reasons I didn't vote
for Trump in 2016 was that interview
that he did with Jake Tapper where he
suddenly forgot what the KKK was and who
David Duke was five minutes before the
Louisiana primary so I have been very
critical I ripped the president Trump a
new one after Charlotte's ville so I am
warmed to the idea that President Trump
has been too soft on groups of people
that he finds benefit him politically
even if they happen to be gross but
Cohen using the the bleep holes example
as in as evidence of racism I never
really bought that argument if you say
that a particular area of the world
like a particular country is a bad place
to live because it is run poorly that
does not make it racist
like I think la frankly is kind of a
bleep hole and I live here and that has
nothing to do with that has done go at
the race of the people who run the city
mayor Garcetti is a is a half Jewish
half Italian I think in private says
Michael Cohen he's even worse and here's
where he gets to the stuff that is bad
for Trump it doesn't fall into illegal
and it doesn't fall into funny it's just
bad he wants he asked me if I could name
a country run by a black person that
wasn't a bleep hole
this is when Barack Obama was President
of the United States is what Michael
Cohen says while we were once driving
through a struggling neighborhood in
Chicago he commented that only black
people could live that way and he told
me that black people would never vote
for him because they were too stupid and
yet I continued to work for him which
does raise the question why you
continued to work for him but
nonetheless nonetheless those are bad
allegations for President Trump
those will make a lot of headlines and
there is no way for Trump to refute that
other than by saying I didn't say that
so that's gonna be he said he said put
that in the bad category for Trump as
opposed to the illegal or the hilarious
category then there is more not great
stuff for Trump but it's not really it
kind of falls into the hilarious just
because we already knew this about Trump
so he says Cohen says mr. Trump is a
cheat as previously stated I'm giving
the committee today three years of
president Trump's financial statements
from 2011 to 2013 which he gave to
Deutsche Bank to inquire about a loan to
buy the Buffalo Bills and to Forbes it
was my experience that mr. Trump
inflated his total assets when it served
his purposes such as trying to be listed
among the wealthiest people in Forbes
and deflated his assets to reduce his
real estate taxes and then it talks
about how he inflated and deflated his
assets for public purposes again that's
mostly hilarious because again it's like
a cheap tactic and we all know that
Trump has been doing this for years I
think Trump has been saying he's worth
10 billion dollars for years that is
absolutely true and he does that
routinely and then he probably properly
reports his income to the government if
not then the IRS could simply go after
him presumably and audit him he says
he's under audit right now mr. Trump
then then we get to something that is in
the bad category and maybe the illegal
category okay that is his use of a
private charity to benefit himself
self-dealing via charity does mr. Trump
directed me to find a straw better to
purchase a portrait of him that was
being auctioned in art Hamptons events
the objective was to ensure that his
portrait will
was going to be auctioned last would go
for the highest price of any portrait
that afternoon the portrait was
purchased by the fake better for 60
grand mr. Trump directed the Trump
Foundation which is supposed to be a
charitable organization to repay the
fake better despite keeping the art for
himself and so that one actually falls
into all three categories it may be
illegal to sign a check from your
foundation to buy a portrait that you
then exhibit in your own private
holdings in your in your Country Club
right that may be illegal it's also bad
in the sense that you shouldn't use
charities that way so it doesn't look
very good
it's also hilarious in the fact that
Trump is such an egotist that he wanted
to make sure that the portrait of him
was the highest bid item of the evening
and who does that legitimately who does
that it's like me going on eBay and
finding somebody who's actioning off one
of my books and then me jacking up the
bidding simply so that I can say that a
bid for like a thousand dollars is it's
so simply and so ridiculous and then
Cohen suggests that Trump is a con man
and there's where he gets to the stormy
Daniel stuff he says I'm giving the
committee today a copy of the one
hundred and thirty thousand dollar wire
transfer from me to stormy Daniels this
attorney during the closing days of the
presidential campaign that was demanded
by Miss Clifford that stormy Daniels to
maintain her silence about her affair
with mr. Trump mr. Trump directed me to
use my own personal funds from a home
equity line of credit to avoid any money
being traced back to him that could
negatively impact his campaign I did
that too without bothering to consider
whether that was improper much less
whether it was the right thing to do or
how it impact me my family or the public
so a couple of things here
now this is an actual allegation of
illegal activity he's suggesting that
Trump new campaign law and that Trump
was explicitly telling him to avoid
campaign disclosures by using his home
equity line of credit so that nothing
could be traced back to him that could
negatively impact his campaign and those
words negatively impact his campaign are
also important because if he had just
told Michael Cohen to pay off this lady
having nothing to do with the campaign
it can't be considered a campaign
expenditure now as I said yesterday on
the program it may still not be
considered a campaign expenditure
because are you actually allowed to use
campaign funds to pay off your
girlfriend's John Edwards case suggests
maybe not but in any case this is at
least a legal allegation like this
actually has some legal importance as
exhibit 5 to my testimony show
as Cohen and providing a copy of a
$35,000 check Trump personally signed
from his personal bank accounts on
August 1st 2017 when he was President of
the United States pursuant to the
cover-up which was the basis of my
guilty plea to reimburse me for the
illegal hush money I paid on his behalf
again the idea here is that President
Trump was doing all of this to avoid
campaign finance law maybe that's true
maybe that's not the SDN why is probably
going to prosecute that but it's a it's
a shaky legal theory it may hold up is
it scummy behavior yeah is a bad
behavior yeah is it anything shocking
from President Trump who presumably was
paying off women for years I mean I'd be
shocked if this is the only time Trump
paid off a woman in fact we know it's
not he did the Karen McDougal to I'd be
shocked if Trump only paid off women
during the campaign that doesn't hold
with what we know about Trump who was
apparently using the National Enquirer
as a go-between to buy off stories as
early as 2011 as he did it to stormy
Daniels I believe in 2011 and then Cohen
says that Trump is a con man here we get
to the hilarious category
he says I'm talking about a man who
declares himself brilliant but directed
me to threaten his high school his
colleges and the College Board she never
released his grades or SAT scores I will
admit when I watched Cohen testify about
this I laughed out loud that is high
warious
because again it just goes to the fact
that Trump is a massive ego test and he
writes a letter to Fordham going if you
release my grades I will come after you
saw her it'll be I'm a of about you have
no hate yeah you I'm at Ed uh-huh
you went after Wharton when different a
school like now I mean honestly now I
want to know what is SAT scores were if
you're threatening people not to release
your SAT scores I'm gonna go with it
wasn't to 1600 maybes was me but if I
had a 1600 on the SATs by the way I
believe I got a 1420 on the SATs I was
also 14 at the time but in any case the
I'm just putting that out there okay so
you know I'm not threatening the SAT
board to not release my SAT scores now
the President of the United States
threatening people natural eases SAT
scores is just fantastic
and then Cohen points out that at the
time Trump was talking about Obama and
ripping him for not releasing his grades
and calling Obama a terrible student
which is just again Trump has no shame
and that is obvious so this one goes in
the hilarious category okay and then he
says then he gets to the main point here
questions have been raised about whether
I know of
recked evidence that mr. Trump or his
campaign colluded with Russia I do not
so why are we here why why are you here
to testify sir you say that you can
provide no evidence that the president
actually colluded with Russia no
evidence that the president actively
worked with WikiLeaks you're saying the
same stuff we already know from SD NY
about all the campaign finance and so
what are you doing here and the answer
of course is the Democrats want
headlines so they can distract from
their own incompetence and garbage
legislation and Cohen shifts the
headlines that's the look that's their
political job this is what you do when
you're a member of a partisan party you
make sure that you humiliate the
President to the other party as much as
possible so I'm not gonna blame
Democrats for doing what Democrats do
it's like blaming the Sun for rising in
the morning none of this is a shock but
if Cohen has nothing about the Russian
collusion stuff why are we here why are
we listening to you you convicted
perjurer former scumbag what are we
doing here
basically all Cohen can testify to is
that he read all over the media then the
summer of 2017 there had been a meeting
in Trump Tower in June 2016 this is the
famous Trump Tower meeting with John Jr
and and a a cut-out lawyer for the
Russians and that there had been lead-up
to the meeting about dirt on Hillary
Clinton and Cohen says something clicked
in my mind I remember being in the room
with mr. Trump probably in early June
2016 so we can't even date it when
something peculiar happened Don junior
came into the room and walked behind his
father's desk which in itself was
unusual people just didn't walk behind
Trump's desk to talk to him really I
recalled Tom jr. leaning over to his
father and speaking in a low voice which
I could clearly hear and saying the
meeting is all set I remember mr. Trump
saying okay good let me know and then he
says well that was clearly about the
Trump Tower meeting is it Murray making
a bunch of sub positions I mean that is
some flimsy legal nonsense so again is
any of this stuff particularly damning
for Trump like more damning than
anything we knew before no it really
isn't is it going to generate a bunch of
bad headlines for president Trump of
course is the RNC handling this about
the worst way they possibly can yeah so
we'll get to that in just one second
first you're gonna have to go over and
subscribe $9.99 a month you get the rest
of this show for for free later once you
subscribe so I guess not for free but
you get to hear
rest of the show later also there two
additional hours so we're gonna bring
you updates throughout the day on
Michael Cohen's testimony and the
fallout if there are any new bombshell
revelations you can go check that out
over at Daly where I come for $99 ear
you also get this the very greatest and
beverage vessels go check it out right
now the leftist tears Hut or cold
tumbler also you get so many more
goodies right later on in the in the day
we're gonna be having on representative
Andy Biggs member of the freedom caucus
to talk about the resolution to block
president Trump's emergency declaration
we're having on representative Ted Yoho
he's member of the House Committee on
Foreign Relations he's here to talk
about the crisis in Venezuela and the
North Korean some it's a lot to get to a
little bit later on in the day this is
why you should subscribe you should also
subscribe so you can be part of our
Sunday special which you will get on
Saturday when you're a subscriber this
week the fantastic Dan Crenshaw stop by
for a full hour chat it was terrific
there's a little bit of what it sounds
like hi I'm congressman Dan Crenshaw I'm
here on the bench Shapiro show where we
talked about my personal history my
future in politics campaign finance the
climate just about everything
tune in so go check that out it's a lot
of fun also a little bit later today if
you if you're a dr. Phil watcher I am on
dr. Phil show we talked about Jesse
Smollett and race crime hoaxes and I'm
on with Andy no as well as as well as
Sally cone there were some fireworks so
you're gonna want to watch that go check
that out
thanks for listening and thanks for
watching leave us a review you tuber
iTunes when you subscribe it always
helps we are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
so as I say nothing that cohen says in
the end is gonna be severely damaging to
trump none of it is great for Trump
because when people get up in public and
say bad things about you that's never
wonderful for for Trump that's never
it's never great for Trump but it is
also true that the RNC has handled this
in the worst possible way
the RNC has become quite Trumpy the
problem is that strategic punch back
would be good all you have to say about
Michael Cohen is the guy's a convicted
perjurer
who is self interested in all of this
testimony he now has an incentive to
make things up about Trump he has an
incentive to remember every bad thing
and the worst possible light for
president Trump because that's how he's
getting a plea deal right that's all you
have to say instead the RNC actually cut
the commercial saying have fun in prison
to Michael Cohen which is just
delightful he's going to do everything
that he promised he's gonna bring
success and he's gonna make America
great compassionate principled Donald
Trump speaks from the heart and pathetic
kind he's gonna stay true to who he is
he's gonna be an amazing president
humble honest and genuine mr. Trump's
memory is fantastic and I've never come
across the situation where mr. Trump has
said something that's acting that's not
accurate Oh Donald Trump wants to do is
Myron I'm sorry the RNC is incompetent
that is such a cellphone so you cut an
entire commercial about about this guy
you say is a lie or saying nice things
about Trump that is your proof that he
is a liar guys do better I mean hello
pretty amazing by the way Cohan has also
testified that he would not call
anything regarding President Trump and
Russia actual collusion so why are we
here what are we talking about what are
we talking about also Republicans are
doing the job representative Jim Jordan
was on the program last week we talked a
little bit about Michael Cohen appearing
before the House Oversight Committee he
pointed out that Michael Cohen is not
just a liar with regard to President
Trump or the Trump Tower meeting that
Michael Cohen is indeed a very bad man I
mean he's going to jail not only because
of his activities with regard to
President Trump or lying to Congress
he's going to jail because he was
involved in a taxi medallion fraud
scheme and the guy is a gross human he's
a bad human
now again none of that means that Trump
is clean but it does mean that if you're
gonna find a witness to go after
President Trump Democrats may want to do
better than that it's it's really yeah
yeah okay so with all of that said
controversy continues to rage over
president Trump's visit to North Korea
the presidents of the United States in
Vietnam right now and apparently he is
watching all of this from afar we'll get
to that in just one second so and the
president is in Vietnam it is unclear
that anything of worth is going to
happen in Vietnam I highly doubtful that
anything of worth will happen apparently
he's staying up all night to watch cons
testimony which again the fact that
that's been leaked is not great for the
president you actually do not want it
known that you are so bothered about
what Michael Cohen is going to say that
you're staying up all night watching it
the proper responses why would I care
what Michael Cohen has to say dudes a
liar he's going to jail for perjury so
now I'm not losing one wink of sleep
over Michael Cohen nonetheless the
president apparently is watching that
from afar I would not expect big things
from the from the Vietnam contingent
over it from from the Vietnam meetings
that are happening right now simply
because North Korea has lied often
continuously all the time about making a
deal with the United States and they
never have really done so right now
according to the CNN President Trump
departed dinner with North Korea's Kim
jong-un at the Metropole Hotel Trump
left the hotel one hour and 42 minutes
after the dinner began the two are
supposed to meet tomorrow for extended
bilateral meetings before President
Trump departs in the evening for
Washington also there will be a Trump
press conference / Trump this evening
they are waiting on the official
schedule with the timing meanwhile
hilariously enough the prospect of
nuclear war is like tertiary in the news
it's the third thing in the news there's
a massive possibility of an escalation
of conflict between Pakistan and India
two nuclear-armed powers according to
Fox News calm tension between two of the
world's nuclear powers were raised
dramatically on Wednesday after
Pakistan's air force said it shot down
two Indian warplanes that crossed the
disputed Kashmir border and captured
each of the aircraft pilots
and there's actual video of people on
the ground in Pakistan beating up one of
the Indian pilots which does not seem
like it complies with the Geneva
Conventions police officials in Indian
Occupied Kashmir told Reuters that two
indian pilots and a civilian on the
ground died when the planes crashed the
officials did not confirm the planes
were shot down by Pakistani forces one
of the pilots named his Wing Commander
Appa and on varta man was subsequently
shown in a video India's government said
it objected to Pakistan's vulgar display
he was seen in two videos one where he
appeared blindfolded and bloodied and
then a second one showing him in custody
with the blindfolds removed appearing
visibly more relaxed even complimenting
his captors on a fantastic cup of tea
Ravi Kumar is a spokesperson for India's
Ministry of External Affairs also claims
in Indian Plains shot down a Pakistani
jet fighter although Pakistan tonight
any of its jets had been hit and
photographic evidence had yet to emerge
obviously this is just another example
of tensions being raised
are we in real danger of nuclear war
here highly highly doubtful given the
fact that these tensions are raised on a
fairly regular basis with that said is
that a bit of a big story yeah it's a
bit of a big story in smaller news in
smaller news apparently AOC is very
upset today why because someone took a
photograph of one of her staffers eating
a hamburger so somebody actually took a
picture of her sitting with one of her
staffers and pointed out that her
staffers eating a hamburgers and Ocasio
cortes ofcourse has said that her
staffers should not in fact eat
hamburgers that that people should not
eat hamburgers it's a very bad thing to
eat hamburgers aoc then fought back by
saying it's so mean that people are
taking pictures of me she said tonight a
dude was creepily and obviously taking a
picture of me while pretending he wasn't
and I had to break his imaginary fourth
wall and say hi I'm a person this is
weird okay so just to get this straight
the media who will dutifully repeat her
talking point dutifully repeat that
talking point these are the same people
who were fine with Ted Cruz and his wife
being attacked in a restaurant by a
bunch of protesters but if you take a
picture of her chief of staff eating a
giant hamburger like a day after ALC
says we shouldn't eat hamburgers then
that is very bad that's how we know that
things are bad we know that things are
bad because someone took a picture of
AOC very very terrible stuff so that is
the latest from AOC also a hilarious
story from AOC the Washington Examiner
is saying that AOC
was bragging about raising her lowest
wage at the office to fifty two thousand
dollars a year actually did this because
it allowed members of her staff to avoid
financial disclosures according to the
Washington Examiner a o'seas decision to
cap her office salaries at 80 grand will
let her chief of staff and senior
employees avoid public transparency laws
that would require them to reveal
outside income gifts in stock trading
activity the New York Democrat announced
last week should institute a living wage
in her office paying staff members a
minimum of fifty two thousand a year and
a maximum of 80,000 a year under federal
law congressional employees who are more
than 126 thousand a year which includes
most Chiefs of Staff must submit public
financial disclosure forms the detail
outside income they earn stock
investments debt gifts or paid trips
they are given by outside sources of
course her chief of staff's got him Sai
cats Chakrabarty and he would be
shielded from public disclosure laws
because he's not going to be paid enough
so is that the real reason that she's
doing all of this who the hell knows but
it is sort of weird that the average
salary for a chief of staff in the house
was one hundred and forty seven thousand
dollars in 2015 but Ocasio courts head
is gonna cap her senior staff salaries
at $80,000 and now they'll be able to
earn outside income without publicly
revealing the amount or the source so
good stuff from the very non swampy very
fresh-faced AOC by the way you wonder
why the Democrats are so eager to push
on Michael Cohen and push Michael Khan
to the top of the news maybe it's
because they can't stop their own
Congress people from saying inane things
for example representative Mary Kay
Scanlon said yesterday said yesterday in
committee hearing that the border agents
for the United States are akin to Nazi
collaborators I've been struck a couple
times by the denial of humanity of many
of these families and children when the
issue is framed as an invasion by aliens
and when we refer to children as UA sees
it's easier to pretend they're not human
or worthy of compassion this hearing is
a recognition and an insistence that on
that humanity a recognition that the
Flores decision also addressed and a
recognition that just following orders
is no more an excuse to
than it was back in Germany don't worry
Democrats are not extreme at all they're
just comparing ice agents to Nazi
collaborators yeah they're they're not
extreme at all I wonder why they're
getting Michael Cohen to testify that
wasn't the only crazy statement
yesterday by the way there's another
Democratic congressman who suggested
that they believe this is hank thompson
who suggested that the only way to
prevent all gun violence is to take away
every gun every day a hundred and
seventy felons and fifty domestic
abusers are stopped from buying a gun at
licensed dealers because of the
background check it works we know it
works there's a lot of evidence out
there that suggests that that clarifies
the fact that it works and as far as
anybody who says well this bill wouldn't
have solved this this incident the only
thing that will solve everyone is to do
away with guns so are you telling me
that the critics of my bill want to do
away with all guns um okay so this is
wild stuff that's Mike Thompson by the
way a representative from California
okay time for some things I like and
then some things that I hate so things
that I like last night I went to a
private screening for a movie called we
die young now it's not a perfect movie
it's coming out video-on-demand on
Friday it is also available in select
theaters across the country it's worth
to watch the reason that's worth the
watch is because it is an actual take on
ms-13 so you've heard president Trump
talk about the dangers of ms-13 what
they do how brutal they are the
depiction of ms-13 in this movie is
excellent and the movies called we die
young and jean-claude Van Damme but it's
Van Damme playing kind of a different
part it's not vans 'i'm kicking people
in the face van zan plays an ex-marine
who was wounded in combat and now he has
to help out a couple of kids who are
being victimized by the ms-13 cartel
there's some of the performances in this
are really fantastic David Castaneda who
plays the leader of the ms-13 gang is
really terrific it's worth a watch so if
you're looking for something to do on a
Friday night and you want a realistic
take on ms-13 go check out we die young
definitely worth the watch go give it a
look okay other things that I like so
Meghan McCain is the only same thing
left about the view since they'll never
have me on and Megan McCain yesterday
went on an absolute tear against her
co-hosts talking about how
Democrats refuse to vote in favor of
federally penalizing infanticide leaving
babies to die who are born after botched
abortions here is Meghan McCain just
dumping on her fellow hosts rightfully
so if Democrats want to win an election
going forward are you going to be the
party of late term abortion either you
have infanticide let me finish please
are you going is this the platform
you're going to have because when you're
talking about children and you're
talking about being pro-life this is
well out of the mainstream of where
Americans are at I saw you think a baby
born version should be put down this is
why I need a foreign jurist okay and you
keep hearing people trying to make
excuses for not voting for the bill
there is no excuse for not voting for
the bill yesterday on the radio version
of the program the additional two hours
we do later in the day that you can get
only if you subscribe senator Ben Sasse
stopped by from Nebraska is one of the
co-sponsors of this bill he explained
what the bill does the bill does not in
any way violate a woman's quote/unquote
right to choose it doesn't even have to
do with abortion it says if a baby is
born after an attempted abortion you
have to transfer the baby to the
hospital and give it the same care you
would give any other infant and it
penalizes doctors who failed to do so or
who leave the baby on the table to die
that's all the bill does and Democrats
opposed it which is insane it is fully
insane and there's no excuse for it and
trying to paint it as a pro-choice issue
is beyond crazy okay so good for Megan
McCain time for a couple of things that
I hate okay so the thing that I hate
number one The Hollywood Reporter isn't
you knew this was coming
you knew it was just a matter of time
until the left openly started defending
jussie Smollett the reason that you knew
this is because they were already on the
verge of doing this when it came out
that it was a hoax that the whole thing
was a hoax now as I say if you want to
hear my fuller take on this I was on dr.
Phil's show that is airing today with
Andy no of Collette as well as Sally
Cohen who's a left contributor for CNN I
believe and we talked about hate crime
hoaxes and and we sort of went through
all of the various issues surrounding
hate crime hoaxes and hate crimes
or generally well The Hollywood Reporter
is now headlining Hollywood hoax and
then their suggestion is I kid you not
that the reason that Jesse Smollett was
doing all of this is because he was
famous like this is their actual
contention they are trying to suggest
that being famous causes you that Fame
causes you to actually participate in
race crime hoaxes that's on their cover
it says jussie Smollett says he's the
victim of a heinous hate crime my career
pressure and so an addictive Fame may
have driven the may have driven him to
do all of this it's what so being super
famous here it says Jesse somewhat says
he's the victim of a heinous hate crime
but career pressure an addictive fame a
have driven the Empire started to do
something desperate really addictive
Fame so I have achieved a certain level
of notoriety I know I wake up every
morning I think you know what I should
probably do claim a hate crime just out
of nowhere just do it haven't you I'd
probably get away with it right like I
could probably just go out there and be
like you know I was walking down the
street two o'clock in the morning coming
back from my kosher hot dog stand and I
was beat up by a couple of people who
were screaming at me a damn Jew I got
that every morning I have to convince
myself it's a bad idea because I'm
famous
it's the fame that makes me do it it's
the addictions of Fame that make me hoax
hey what what so now he's a victim he's
a victim of his own fame what Absolut's
shared garbage that wasn't even the
worst take on justice Millette the other
one is still from The Hollywood Reporter
but it comes courtesy of Ellen Page who
is really who has acted violently with
regard to this stuff I mean really acted
violently went on national television
blamed Mike Pence for a fake hate crime
and then suggested that Mike Pence's
perspective on the sinfulness of
homosexuality is responsible for vast
swaths of hate crimes happening across
the country so she has an entire column
today that is called hate violence is
not a hoax so in other words I got the
hate crime hoax wrong but the general
point which is that hate crimes occurred
that's not wrong you'll see this is
something that folks on the Left want
that's not the story we all acknowledge
that there are such things as hate
crimes although they are exceedingly
rare the number of actual federal hate
crimes prosecuted in 27 and 2018 by the
federal government is 50 this is a
country of three hundred and thirty
seven million people we stopped
around every corner look some a guy had
it racist seeking to be up a gay black
guy like it's just not true this is an
insanely tolerant wonderful country and
I'm speaking as a Jew who hires security
to go from place to place because I get
death threats okay so I am saying this
is a wonderful incredible tolerant
country you know why because it is and
this notion that well you know it was at
least at least Jesse Smollett was a
pathway to conversation at least what
jussie Smollett shows is not that
Americans don't take hate crime
seriously enough it's that we take hate
crime so seriously we are even willing
to grant credibility to some of the
flimsiest garbage east stories ever told
by people like Jesse Samoa that's how
seriously we take hate crimes is that
the mark of a country that is deeply
evil and deeply terrible and deeply
hateful I really don't think so I really
don't think so okay so as I say tune in
later today we have two more hours we'll
be covering more of Michael Khan's
testimony I am sure plus go check out
dr. Phil today because I think there was
some spicy stuff in that episode and
we'll either see it here later today if
you subscribe or we'll see you here
tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Adam sy events
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wired production
copyright daily wire 20 19